hi welcome back everyone so now what
we're gonna do is go a little bit more
into depth on the Koopman operator
optimal control example from this paper
commune observable subspaces
and finite linear representations of
nonlinear dynamical systems for control
again you can read more about this on
the archive we have the code for this
included so you can run this in MATLAB
yourself and play around with it and
here are my co-authors so recall that in
some cases if I have a nonlinear
dynamical system I can augment my state
variables with some nonlinear observable
functions of my state variables so in
this case its y1 equals my first
variable x1 y2 equals my second variable
x2 + y3 equals x1 squared and in some
cases I can write my nonlinear dynamical
system as a linear system in terms of
these nonlinear observable functions of
my state which is really neat and when
we can do this it's possible to develop
an optimal controller using the Koopman
linear system and this is something
we're terming Koopman operator optimal
control okay so for this nonlinear
system here we've now added inputs U and
we can develop lqr controller for this
Koopman linear system with inputs so
that we stabilize our system without
spending too much control energy and one
of the really nice things that comes out
of this is that we have this nonlinear
term in our Koopman optimal controller
okay so these are nonlinear controllers
and the derive from things like lqr on
the the Koopman operator so now we're
going to jump into some MATLAB and
actually look at how we generated these
these figures and how we code this up
using the built in MATLAB lqr function
okay you can download this code yourself
it's on it's on the archive in our paper
but I'm just going to walk you through
some of the steps here so that we can
see see what's happening so the first
thing we're gonna do if we were if we
were approaching this nonlinear system
without any knowledge of the Koopman
operator what we might do naively is try
to stabilize this system using a
linearization about the fixed point zero
zero so here what I'm doing is I'm
defining a linear system we have an a
matrix and a B matrix so this is a
linear system X dot equals ax plus B u a
two-by-two linear system with a single
input and this is linearized about the
zero condition and I'm going to define a
vector field here which is a function of
time my state variable and my control
input and it's got my linearized term a
times X plus this nonlinear term I had
this minus lambda x1 squared minus B
times my controller maybe I should make
this plus B times my controller ok and
what we can do is right off the bat we
can develop an lqr controller here all
we have to do is specify some weights Q
and R and Q penalize is how much my
state deviates from the stable zero
condition that I want to stabilize and R
tells me how much I penalize control
expenditure ok so here I'm just using
this lqr on a linear system I just
create an identity matrix for Q and R is
one so I'm kind of penalizing all states
and control equally and with one line in
MATLAB this lqr command I can build an
lqr controller given my dynamics a my
input matrix B and my cost weights q and
r and so this C function essentially
this C matrix tells me that my
controller my optimal control law at
least on a linearized sense for small
deviations is u equals minus this matrix
C times X really simple to implement ok
so this is called proportional feedback
control and this matrix of gains C this
is a 2 by 1 matrix sorry two column one
row matrix is given by this lqr command
so i'm just going to run these and good
we have that
now we have that we can go into our
command window and we can type see and
we can see that this is actually the the
lqr gain matrix that came out for this a
matrix and this B matrix okay and then I
can actually integrate the full
nonlinear dynamics using this this
controller u equals minus CX that we
defined using lqr above so I'm just
going to run this good now we have T and
X lqr and we'll be able to plot this and
see you know what the what the
controlled dynamics really look like
okay so it makes sense
pretty straightforward this is you know
basically intro controls you know easy
to do in MATLAB but what we're gonna
find is that since we have this Koopman
operator this this bigger a matrix on my
Y vector we can also develop an optimal
control law and lqr controller using
this new Koopman a and b matrix so I'm
doing the same thing here I'm defining a
a2 and b2 those are my Koopman my
Koopman operators and now I have a new
cost weight q2 and I'm penalizing the
first state X 1 the second state X 2 and
I'm putting no penalty at all on this
kind of fictitious nonlinear third state
Y 3 equals x1 squared so this q2 really
is the exact cost function that I used
before but now I'm applying it to my
larger state Y and again I'm penalizing
control with a unit gain and so this
turns out to be really really simple all
I have to do is I can develop this new
control law c2 using the same lqr
commands in MATLAB and once I have that
I can run this through my vector field I
can run this through the same OD 45 with
my same vector field except now I'm
giving it - proportional gains times X -
proportional gain times you know the
third
for Chanel gain times x1 squared okay
and these need to be minus signs okay so
if I run this one and I go to my command
window I should see that now my new
Koopman control gain matrix has three
elements right so this is the first two
are the same as my my lqr on the
linearized state but now I pick up this
third gain entry here and this
corresponds to u equals minus c2 see
this is my new C times my Y vector and
so this is minus c1 c2 x1 x2 minus C 3
x1 squared ok these are the the entries
the first second and third entries of
this new new gain matrix and so that's
why we see that in our in our integrator
here our vector field for this u slot
our control slot we're giving it - the
first two elements times X - the third
element times x1 squared that's exactly
what we have here and I can simulate
this just like before
good we've run that and now if I just
start plotting everything I want to plot
the x1 and x2 coordinates for both of
these controllers and I also want to
look at how the cost function evolves
over time did I spend more cost or less
costs with Koopman optimal control and
this is just a bunch of plotting command
so I'm not going to go through that but
it brings up this nice visualization
that essentially summarizes the
differences between regular naive lqr on
the linearization and this Koopman
operator optimal control on the
nonlinear ization on this Y vector ok so
this red dashed curve is my Koopman
optimal control solution the white solid
curve is my lqr solution and this is
just my first and second state and so
you can see that it looks like we have a
lot less
daeviation so a lot so our red solution
kind of gets to the the stabilized fixed
point faster so there's less deviation
and if we look on the very far right
here this is our integrated cost
function over time and you can see that
our Koopman optimal controller has much
less integrated cost over time than our
naive linearized lq our optimal
controller in fact it's about 1/3 as
much control and state penalty which is
really amazing so one of the reasons
we're calling this Koopman operator
optimal control is because you're doing
optimal control using the Koopman
operator but also we're finding that
we're getting a nonlinear controller out
you can interpret the output is a
nonlinear controller and for this simple
system it appears like this nonlinear
controller is actually globally optimal
in a nonlinear sense so you can start
with huge initial conditions and you
still get extremely good controller
performance so this is just an overview
of how you can implement this Koopman
operator optimal control if your system
is amenable to this Koopman subspace
subspace methods okay thank you very
much